malgré l'interdiction des rassemblements
la population est de nouveau descendue
dans la rue pour contester le coup
d'état militaire qui a renversé l'ex
chef du gouvernement en scène sushi ce
jeudi de nombreux fonctionnaires sont
venues gonfler les rangs des cortèges
dans plusieurs villes du pays
une initiative condamnée par le pouvoir
militaire qui a lancé un nouvel
avertissement à la population en raison
de l'incitation de personnes peu
scrupuleuses certains membres du
personnel de la fonction publique n'ont
pas rempli leurs fonctions ces personnes
perturbe le personnel de la fonction
publique qui travaille pour le pays et
la population milieu de nombreuses
difficultés certaines mesures ont déjà
été publiés des actions efficaces seront
prises le pouvoir se montre de plus en
plus répressif mardi l'intervention de
la police a fait plusieurs blessés dans
les rangs des manifestants
dans 2 toujours dans un état grave une
escalade de la violence
une nouvelle fois condamnée par la
communauté internationale les états unis
par la voix de joe biden ont annoncé des
sanctions financières contre les chefs
militaires rapidement imité ce jeudi par
le royaume uni la communauté
internationale n'acceptera pas le coup
d'état en birmanie et nous demanderons
des comptes aux responsables le royaume
uni félicite la décision du président
des états unis d'envoyer un message fort
aux militaires le royaume uni envisage
d'urgence de nouvelles mesures dans le
cadre de notre propre batterie de
sanctions la communauté internationale
suit de très près l'évolution de la
situation en birmanie
les européens ont remis ce jeudi au
conseil des droits de l'homme de l'onu
un projet de résolution condamnant le
coup d'état militaire
un texte qui doit être débattu ce
vendredi au cours d'une session
extraordinaire à ce sujet la position de
moscou
ou encore de pékin soutiens
traditionnels de l'armée birmane aux
nations unies se raconte à l scrutées de
près